we need to get to an all-american
morning must-read here's Olivia sturgeon
all-american warning must read a quote
from a Canadian living in Italy running
an American car company Sergio Marconi
was at Bloomberg HQ yesterday the CEO of
Fiat Chrysler sat down and spoke to us
about taking Ferrari public during the
interview he said quote the execution of
this is going to be very short we just
need to be very focused on which
investor base were going after and once
we do that you could probably sell it by
the time you and I have a bagel in the
morning so Sergio Marconi boasting about
how easy it will be to take for our
Republic Bob Nardelli still with us on
set he used to run chrysler bob would
you rather buy a ferrari or Ferrari
stock probably the Ferrari no but I
think Sergio's right I think he'll I
think that's a that's a fair expectation
I mean it's it's an unbelievable brand
it has tremendous aspiration I think the
stock will do great I think he has plans
to increase production I think that was
one of the issues from 7,000 to 10,000 a
year I think it'll do very well help us
understand the force of Sergio Marconi's
personality and he worked his way into
the family that owned Fiat he's now
traveling you know almost every day
between continents how much of a role
does his personality play in that
company right now well I think it's huge
I mean he has he has tremendous presence
he's a very intelligent negotiator as
you said he has worked his way into the
family and displaced many of them and
there he is with that for those on radio
he's standing next to John Elk and the
chairman of Fiat and x-ray yeah I think
you know John is certainly the head I
mean the face to to it but I think
Sergio really is running and pulling all
the strings I mean he did a an
unbelievable job in negotiations with
the government to get Chrysler free as I
said before one of the greatest American
giveaways certainly in my business
lifetime but I give him credit he's a
shrewd operator and negotiator what do
you think about the stock obviously it's
up 27% year today and actually I also
spoke to Bill Miller
Legg Mason's chairman CIO who is also in
Bloomberg HQ yesterday and he is bullish
on Fiat Bob and this is why he just
talks about precisely what we're talking
about spinning off Ferrari the fact that
it has a gyro based currency but big
North America business it also has the
ability to take
cheap global while introducing Alfa
Romeo here
very smart supportive parent and XOR as
well going back to that relationship
with Elkins do you agree with mr. Miller
well I think partially I do Olivia I
mean I think Chrysler is what has
support at Fiat if you'll reflect back
without Chrysler Fiat would have gone in
bankruptcy right I mean it was
Chrysler's products it was Chrysler's
cash that has kept Fiat alive over the
last few years so maybe they should
spend Chrysler off again